hi there and thanks for joining this
presentation i'm chris deeks one of the
field sales managers at cooled
and today i'll be talking and discussing
led illumination in life science
research
specifically for fluorescence microscopy
in this presentation i'll look at three
main points we'll see why leds are the
now the go-to option for fluorescence
microscopy
and the benefits they provide look at
why they originally had some
shortcomings compared to mercury lamps
and how these have been overcome
and actually two questions regarding
these shortcomings often come up
firstly a wavelength available for my
chosen flora4 and secondly is it bright
enough
so i'll explain why these are actually
hangovers of when the technology was
still maturing
and finally i'll look at how leds are
not just a light source replacement for
a mercury lamp that can just be put on a
system
but how they can actually be fully
involved in a smart system setup and
help provide better imaging for the user
so at cooled we work solely with leds as
a light emitter
and these leds come with large benefits
one of them being a long lifetime
compared to mercury bulbs
with leds having a lifetime of over
twenty thousand hours when used in this
manner
leds themselves actually have a life
expectancy of over a hundred thousand
hours
but to get the extra brightness out of
them we over drive them slightly
this is absolutely fine to do as long as
they're cooled sufficiently
which we do in our products mercury
bulbs however have a lifetime of about
200 hours before they become a lot
dimmer compared to when they were new
they can last longer than this but the
more it's used the dim of the output
which then restricts the ability to get
high quality images from experiments
over a longer time period leds also
don't have any warm up or cool down time
which mercury bulbs do
leds can be switched on and off as much
as is needed without any problems
whereas with mercury bulbs they require
about 20 minutes to warm up before they
reach their most bright
and then when switching them off they
have to stay off for around half hour or
so before they can be switched on again
this means actually most of the time the
lamps are kept on during the day in labs
just in case anyone needs to use them
this actually deteriorates them quickly
and also cuts short their lifetime
mercury lamps also give a broad white
spectrum whereas leds give much narrower
bands
and these often come with independent
channel intensity control as well
so if a wavelength is not needed those
leds can remain switched off
or if several leds are in an
illumination system they can easily be
adjusted to change the intensity
which makes it perfect for balancing
fluorophores on samples without the need
for an nd filter
here you can see a typical setup of an
old style mercury lamp with a lot of
cumbersome features that are not
required
when working with led sources an
electric shutter is no longer needed as
leds can be switched on and off with no
warm-up time is just discussed
nd filters aren't needed due to the
precise intensity control in led units
and as leds provide narrow bandwidths of
light excitation filters can now be
placed into units in front of their
respective leds
to prevent excitation filter wheels
being needed
these benefits give a cost reduction but
also prevent things like vibration which
can occur
from all these mechanical parts in a
setup it can also provide much faster
imaging than was previously possible as
well
leds are now the preferred option for
lighting on microscopes
and they now fit most old and new models
microscopes do have different optical
path lens but this can be dealt with in
several ways
for example in our p300 series direct
fit model we have an adjuster that moves
an optical lens
so the light reaching the sample can
provide the best homogeneity
with our liquid light guide units these
typically use a collimator which can be
adjusted
again to improve the brightness and
homogeneity on the sample between all
the different microscopes
as it isn't one size fits all so i
mentioned at the beginning of this
presentation
two questions often come up when people
were still unsure about using leds
so look at these now
first one of these questions was
regarding leds and coverage of the
wavelengths
so here you can see a chart showing the
available wavelengths on our pe 100 unit
where any single led can be chosen from
a range of 20.
we can see the range here from 365
nanometers in the uv
up to 770 nanometers in the infrared
however our p340 fury unit also provides
a 340 nanometer led
for applications requiring this
wavelength so we can go further into the
uv if required
this range of wavelengths provides the
ability to work with the majority of
stains
in the research and clinical fields
however leds themselves can actually go
far beyond this
in the infrared to about 1700 nanometers
and down
into the uv to wavelengths of around 260
nanometers
for applications such as sterilization
these aren't typically used in more
routine microscopy
applications at the moment but this
could change
one weakness in leds is they do have
less power in the green region
but as you can see in the graph here one
way to aid this is to create a broader
peak
so this is done by fostering an led
which gives us this broadness
so at cool ed we use a very strong blue
led with the phosphor on top
which is very efficient and gives very
good brightness other methods include
using a laser to excite the phosphor
this would obviously require a laser in
the system which can add cost
and could be a health and safety issue
as well but as you can see it's clear
leds do cover a broad spectral region
but often on microscopes more than one
wavelength is needed to look at
different fluorophores
so it's common for led units to be
fitted with more than one led
it's quite common for them at the moment
to have three or four in in fact one of
our units the p4000 is fitted with 16
leds
giving a broad array of wavelengths
available to use
but even with a broad choice of
wavelengths it's important to match the
leds in the units to the excitation
filters in a microscope
to get the best image as possible
the second question often asked is are
leds bright enough
and here we can see a comparison of a
mercury lamp the gray line
compared to one of our p300 series shown
by the blue line
which has three leds fitted the power of
leds has actually greatly increased over
the past years so back in 2006
uh when cool had first released that led
source for fluorescence microscopy
we were at a tiny fraction of the power
at now we can see from the graph here
how we can
compare now with leds being much
brighter in the uv region
and in the blue but the red is slightly
lower than the lamp power still
it's much more flat though and provides
more than enough power for fluorophores
in this region
we actually upgraded this unit a couple
of years ago with new leds providing
over
double the power output compared to the
original leds we used
in fact led power is roughly doubling
every two to three years or so
so it's going to be a matter of time
before they're even brighter in the red
and all the other regions as well
we've actually been told by some people
though that led power is more than
enough
now and i've seen talks and papers
suggesting can be better to excite
flora4s with less power
but for an extended time period so some
people do still want the power though
but we can say
obviously the power is there one thing
to remember is when the power is quoted
this can be
quite a confusing element often it's not
the power that's measured at the sample
itself
so we actually tend to use the word
irradiance and this is actually the
power
over the area and this is quoted in
milliwatts per millimeter squared
this gives a much a better idea of
what's happening at the sample which is
where the graph here was actually
measured as well occasionally you may
see the power quoted as out of a light
guide as well
but this doesn't reflect the light that
actually makes it to the sample so it
can be misleading as it doesn't factor
in variable losses through the light
path
of different microscopes and we've
actually created a couple of white
papers recently explaining how to
accurately and precisely measure
irradiance
so if you're interested you can find
this either on our website or available
to download on our booth as well
so we've discussed the convenience of
leds providing the long lifetime the
instant on off and the fact there's no
mercury
but leds actually offer many additional
benefits in terms of the performance and
quality of data that can be collected
so leds are not just a dumb lamp like
you get with mercury
but can actually provide sophisticated
control and can lead to
improvements in the image by improving
the signal to noise
it can also help reduce photo bleaching
meaning it can
image for longer and improve the cell
viability as well
this actually comes down to the narrow
bandwidth of the leds and the high speed
of the control you can get
you can take a couple of looks at some
examples now
so here's an image showing the reason
why the signal to noise is improved
as you can see the gray line is a
spectrum from the metal halide lamp
and the blue is the 435 nanometer led
bulb
for exciting something like cfp you can
actually see how well
this fits into the excitation filter
pass band shown by the solid
red line on the left there's actually
very little of the led energy that falls
into the emission
filter pass band that's important for
reducing the background and improving
the signal-to-noise ratio
so the optical filters provide a great
job obviously blocking the light from
unwanted wavelengths
but with the narrow bands from the led
it improves the data even further by
doing this compared to
mercury lamps narrow band of the led
means
less uv light is also reaching your
sample as well
so for every uv photon that reaches your
sample it can be causing background
fluorescence
and can be causing damage to samples as
well
so using leds can have quite big
advantages for data collection
and actually a study by sandrine prost
in 2016
showed some nice signal-to-noise
improvements of between two and seven
times with leds compared to lamp-based
sources
which is pretty incredible to see
so in terms of improving cell viability
this comes down to high speed switching
in fact one of the biggest improvements
is about being able to synchronize the
on and off with the exposure of the
camera
with the led light source and this can
be done via usb
if the light source is integrated into
the software or via a ttl line from the
camera to an led light source
so reducing or removing the needless
light illumination from either side of
the camera exposure
goes a big way to reduce photo bleaching
from when shutters were used
or in fact when fast switching isn't
used at all and this will improve cell
viability
one method that has been discussed as
well is to use very fast pulsing
rather than continuous illumination this
can be a
few microseconds pulse followed by a
rest time to allow the excited
fluorophores to come back down to ground
state
and again followed by another pulse and
so on this has been shown to improve
cell viability and reduce photo
bleaching
you can actually see how this was
studied in the paper referenced here
so leds can be used not only for
fluorescence applications but for
transmitted ones as well
typically halogen bulbs have been used
for transmitted light
this causes a color change when the
intensity is altered
with leds the color temperature stays
the same with varying intensity
giving much more repeatable results for
experiments
with halogen users also like to keep the
lamp on about a 9 volt setting which
gives a color temperature of around 3000
so keeping the cold temperature at this
with leds means the intensity can be
varied
without affecting any work that's being
done
another element that's important for
transmitted light leds
is the correlated color temperature and
that's achieved by balancing the led
and giving it a good green and red
region a poor led is very cold to the
eye with higher intensity in the blue
but leds are also much more favorable in
the uv as well
and it gives minimal illumination in
this wavelength region
so it's much easier on the eye than a
halogen bulb which has a higher
irradiance in the uv
which can cause things like dryness of
the eye
so in summary we've seen leds have huge
benefits over traditional lamps
now more than ever with their increasing
brightness and their large range of leds
that are now available
so they give cost savings as well as
providing ease of use
and can provide better quality imaging
as well
so the future of leds also looks good
with ever improving brightness meaning
irradiance will improve
and make data collecting even easier for
the user
so thanks everyone for listening and
thanks to andor for organizing this
conference
feel free to drop by our booth either
myself or or my colleagues will be
available to answer any questions
or you can drop me an email or give us a
call using the information here as well
so thank you very much